Emma a single mum of one is among
millions of ordinary britons For Whom
the daily challenge of balancing Rising
bills for eating and heating is only
likely to get harder
social life goes out of the window now
only things that I can do with my son
are free things it's basically going to
be that we don't put the heating on so
we're going to have to find ways that um
to keep ourselves warm
worse is yet to come with average energy
bills forecast to rise to more than
three thousand pounds in October and as
high as 3 800 pounds by January without
more direct government help one energy
supplier told me there will be dire
consequences for millions of households
that's precisely why we called for more
intervention earlier in the year is
because we could see up to 40 percent of
our customer base going into fuel
poverty which is why we need more
short-term health
while households face Rising bills
energy companies enjoy steepling profits
British gas owner centrico recorded
half-year profits of 1.3 billion pounds
largely from oil and gas extraction a
five-fold increase on 262 million pounds
last year it said British gas profits
had fallen to 98 million pounds because
the price cap means it's selling some
power below cost but it will pay a 59
billion pound dividend to shareholders
oil giant shell meanwhile declared a
record 9.5 billion pound quarterly
profit more than double the 4.5 billion
pounds last year and will return almost
5 billion pounds to shareholders through
a share buyback along with a warning of
gas shortages
it may well be that we are facing a very
tough winter uh of course it's it's
speculative we don't know what's going
to happen we don't know uh what will
happen in and around Russia but it would
be foolish not to prepare for a
contingency where we have significantly
uh smaller gas supplies
energy companies say they need to make
profits so they can invest in cleaner
Greener Technologies and ensure they're
robust enough to keep supplying us with
fuel and power but as long as they are
making huge profits from a price surge
caused by War and sharing the proceeds
with shareholders rather than customers
they will face criticism and political
pressure
the government has already imposed a
windfall tax under pressure from labor
and energy tax cuts are promised without
even more help it could be a dire winter
for consumers Paul Kelso Sky News